les machines tournent pas à plein régime
les petites pièces destinées aux avions
se succèdent et les commandes des
clients se multiplient c'est la relance
de l'activité dans l'usiné permaswage
des clayes-sous-bois après une année
2009 difficile à cause de la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui on est encore à 20
25 % en dessous de l'activité j'allais
dire en 3 8 de l'ensemble des
installations de production qu'on a sur
le site ce site industriel du groupe
américain est un sous traitant des
constructeurs d'avions leur spécialité
la fabrication de ces pièces pour former
la tuyauterie des avions si j'ai
travaillé 32 heures par semaine il y a
quelques mois stéphane est revenu
aujourd'hui à des semaines de 35 heures
voix par rapport à ce qu'on a à faire
derrière le le cadencement
il voit on voit que les panels sont bien
remplies et que oui ça on voit que ça
mais c'est pas savons pas non plus
vertigineuse monde c'est s'est doucement
mais sûrement on va dire si à un moment
la délocalisation du site étaient
envisagés il ya un peu moins d'un an un
accord social et le chômage partiel a
maintenu lusine aux clayes-sous-bois la
mise en place de ce régime à peine des a
permis de baisser les tensions et de
nous organiser de façon à ce que ni
aucune perte aucune casse sociale dans
l'entreprise avec l'augmentation de la
cadence de production de l'a320 par
airbus les perspectives sont bonnes pour
permettre aux ide ont été sur l'année
2020 40 appareils par mois et on
passerait à
49,50
dès l'année prochaine donc une
augmentation significative fin 2022
début 2023 permaswage prévoit de
réaliser 90 % du chiffre d'affaires
réalisé en 2019 à condition de gérer les
problématiques suivantes la gestion de
l'approvisionnement la hausse des coûts
sur les matériaux de production ou
encore la montée en compétences